and you guys were absolutely brilliant
in this film you good yes grooving
you're good your tinted specs we made
you look like a real pie is sleazy kind
of pie and your specs made you look
really brilliant so I loved you guys in
your characters there's a lot of
swearing in this this movie so yeah so
what is your go-to curse word I like you
do use that in general I do I do for
sometimes your shock tactics is
sometimes just cuz I like it
okay and yours I don't cuz you don't
curse at all you know no bad words no
like nothing no not even nothing nothing
no wow and you know what I loved about
this film was the fact that Guy Ritchie
took this film to show about the way
social media is used you do whatever you
have to do to make something go viral
and there's that video where they're
fighting
they are breakdancing what do you love
about social media
literally nothing yeah actually it
should be erased from the face of the
earth no I don't do any social media I
think it's detestable I think it's the
it's the it's the beginning of the end
really yeah and yourself nothing well I
I've always hated it then I got involved
with a political campaign in London and
my friends persuaded me to have a
Twitter account and I was very reluctant
to do and I regret it to this day
are you active do you you tweet right we
are I was very active during the
election and do you like a bit of social
media a little bit yeah I enjoy it there
you get to connect with people all right
the best part of it I think that's the
fun part of it all right in a more
satisfying way than actually connecting
with people in this sort of I would love
to reason channel why do this and have a
drink and yeah but that doesn't happen
often anymore does it well I think that
that by virtue of the fact that oh you
know social media is overtaking that and
I think that might be one of the
problems you know the problem for me is
that it creates a filter and a safety
and it's in its terraforming the way
people interact with each other and this
there is not as much courtesy and
there's a there's a boldness
that I think that that leans in and in a
negative way to people's propensity to
be negative to each other you know where
is it takes you know it takes an
enormous set of balls and courage and
lack of empathy you know to say some of
the things that people are like very
willing to just you know send off a
message you actually say that to
somebody's face it would be appalling
and so but the recipients this the the
the end results is the same for the
recipient so so I won't make waste too
much time talk about social media but I
think I think it is and I think it is
quite a damaging I think it's cannot can
have quite a damaging effect on the way
we interact I love that it's well said
well said
in 1999 Notting Hill was released it's
been a while what did you think of his
performance in Notting Hill I bet you've
never seen it that you know I don't know
place yeah you haven't seen it it's one
of his best performances did you a lot
well you know I hate my job
I'm very glad that it came out well yeah
people liked it yeah yeah you know one
of the things though as a Canadian and
you guys are both British what are your
thoughts of what's happening with the
worlds right now with the Megan and
Harry stepping back and they're from
their royal duties I think when anybody
has the sort of courage to to seize
autonomy over their life and decide that
they're gonna you know change things up
if they think they aren't working to
find you know happiness or a more
holistic way for them to live it's
admirable
you know they born into those boys were
born into you know some wonderful
privilege and great opportunity but a
crippling sense of responsibility that
they didn't ask for and if he feels like
he can go off and have a more meaningful
existence doing something else they're
more power to him you doin anything
today no no thank you so much both of
you
you